Hi. Hi YouTube. Uh this is Professor
Jang again. Um I am in Toronto. I'm
still trying to recover from the jetlack
and the uh time difference. Um
um as everyone knows um it seems this
war in the Middle East is uh blowing up
and it seems like even though the United
States has yet to declare war on Iran
um it will probably happen um in the
next couple of days with the United
States um bombing Iran.
Um so
um today I'm going to share with you my
impressions, my analysis of what's
happened of what's happening in the
Middle East. Um and I hope that um this
discussion will be clarifying
and illuminating for uh many of you.
So, um it's very clear what the US
intention is.
Um because we've seen what the United
States has done to Iraq, Libya, and
Syria. They call it regime change, but
it's really the destruction of the
society. Um the destruction of the
capacity as a people to be a nation to
work collectively. And the most glaring
example of course is Iraq. um in 2003
before the Americans invaded it was a
fairly well functioning society. Yeah. I
mean there were sanctions that
impoverished the people but overall I
mean it was a fairly stable um society
in middle middle east. United States
goes in over for Osam Hussein. And at
that time you had a lot of people who
welcome this uh transition and this
change and they believe that the
Americans will implement democracy which
was a state mission and it will lead to
a more prosperous Iraq. But very soon
afterwards
the Americans implement a policy called
debuffification
uh which is to remove anyone from the
Baptist party from government from the
military from the police. And the
problem with this is these are the elite
of society. You remove the elite from
society from the pillars of power
society um ceases to function properly.
And that's exactly what happened. It led
to massive sectarian violence that
continues even today in Iraq. So, um I
can't believe that anyone's stupid to
not know the consequences of this policy
of deaf.
Um and so when Americans say regime
change in the Middle East, think of Iraq
2003 and what happened afterwards.
So um the question now is how will the
Americans move forward? Well the
American strategy in the Middle East um
it's been in place for the past 20 years
and regime change requires three
pillars. Okay. The first pillar is um
um decapitation of the leadership. Just
remove the entire leadership. Okay. Uh
second is um revolutionary um intent and
you do that through economic sabotage,
right? For sanctions by by destroying
infrastructure that allows uh people to
live normal lives which includes water
supply, electricity.
Um and the third pillar of the strategy
is to ferment sectarian violence to
divide and conquer the people to take
advantage of the fact that uh within the
societies there are there are these
minorities of people who have have
traitionally traditionally been
suppressed. You give them a promise of a
better life. So in Iraq 2003 you had the
Kurds but you also had uh the Shia the
Shia the Shiites. um um Iran, there are
tons and tons of minorities who are
discontent with the way things are right
now. So that's the American strategy uh
moving forward. And if we want to
clarify or simplify the strategy, we can
use um a metaphor. Okay, Americans to
win wars in the Middle East, they use
bombs, they use propaganda, and um they
use money. Okay, the bombs is basically
you have these fighter jets going in to
destroy uh any military opposition.
Propaganda is CNN, BBC, New York Times
to create the impression that this is
being done in the name of democracy and
prosperity and and peace. And then uh
money in that you are financing a lot of
the opposition groups. You you're
financing a lot of the internal disscent
uh which will overthrow the regime. So
um this strategy, bombs, propaganda,
money, it's also being implemented right
now in Iran. Um and in fact, you can
make argument that this has been going
on secretly underground for many years
now.
Personally, I think the strategy won't
work. Um first of all, bombs don't
really work with the geography of Iran.
Remember Iran, it is a mountainous
terrain. Um, so it's it's a huge huge
country. It's three times the size of
Iraq. So I'm not I'm not um convinced
that um air strikes will do any real
lasting damage to the infrastructure of
Iran.
propaganda. New York Times, CNN, BBC
have absolutely no credibility today.
Not even among among Western domestic
audiences. Um they they have even less
credibility
um um in Iran. And then you have uh
money and um I don't know how effective
money will be because at the end of the
day what differentiates Iran from say
Libya, Syria and Iraq is the people in
Iran consider consider themselves
Persians. In other words, they consider
themselves heroes to a brilliant
creative uh civilization that's been
around for 5,000 years. And um I can't
overstate enough um the motiv how that
would energize and motivate the people
to resist and to uh unite together.
Also what's really important is um the
Iranians saw exactly what happened to
the Iraqis. this once vibrant,
harmonious, um, brilliant um, nation was
destroyed by American nation by by
American sanctions and American air
strikes. Um, so um, I don't think that
the Americans have a compelling case to
make before the Iranian uh, people. So
um this another way of say another way
of saying this is that even though it
seems the Americans have the military
advantage um they are they are still the
greatest military in human history.
The the problem though is the Iranians
have much more strategic flexibility.
And what I mean by that is the Americans
to overthrow this regime need um to
decap decapitate uh the leadership. They
need to create internal disscent, a
revolution, and they need to rally the
religious minorities against the um the
regime in Tran. Okay. And that's really
um the main strategy moving forward and
really the only Oh, there's my son Chris
by the way. Um and that's the only
um real path to victory for the
Americans, whereas the Iranians have
much more strategic flexibility. Okay.
So um in other words, America and its
allies in the Middle East have major
strategic vulnerabilities.
Um let's for example, let's take Saudi
Arabia. Well, Saudi Arabia has two
vulnerable resources that the American
that the that sorry the Iranians at any
time can strike at through the proxies
uh the Houthies, right? You have the
desalination plants which provides which
is the only source of fresh water for
Saudi Arabia. If you knock out the
salination plants in Saudi Arabia, uh
Saudi Arabia loses all its fresh water
in two weeks time and there's no way of
replenishing that fresh water. Then of
course you have the oil fields which are
extremely vulnerable to rocket attacks.
So um Saudi Arabia, the main US ally of
Arab nations in the Middle East, um um
it's extremely vulnerable to um Iranian
attacks. Then you have the trade of
humus which controls a great deal of the
world's trade. If Iran closes that off
then that cuts off cuts off not just oil
to East Asia uh but it cuts cuts off
revenue for American allies like Oman,
Saudi Arabia, uh the UAE,
um Qatar. Um, and the last strategic
vulnerability is you have all sorts of
American bases uh throughout the Middle
East, especially in Kuwait, um,
especially in Saudi Arabia, Qatar, and
these are legitimate military targets if
America declares war on Iran. So, um,
another another way of saying this is
Americans their ability to inflict pain
on Iran. Um, we know it's predictable
and we know that the Iranians can
sustain it because this sanction regime
has been on has been going on for the
past few decades. But the Iranians
ability to inflict pain on American
allies as well as the American military
as well as American consumers
um, well, they're not really
predictable. And ultimately you can make
the argument that because America is not
the Americans people are not in favor of
this war then it's very it's less likely
that uh American consumers will be able
to sustain absorb high oil prices and
inflation that this war would inevitably
cause. So um I would say the main
advantage
um um going into this war just from a
geopolitical uh anecical perspective I
would say it's very much in favor of the
um Iranians. This not this does not mean
that um the Americans and Israelis will
not be able to inflict tremendous damage
on the nation. Um I I mean if America
and Israel continues its bombing
campaign, which I suspect it will for
the next few months, then we will see
tremendous damage um and economic loss
within Iran. Um but ultimately war is
not decided by resources, weapons or
technology. It's not it's really decided
by a people's willingness to fight and
die for what they believe in. And I
think at um when it comes to this
question then I think the Iranians um
have a huge advantage over the
Americans. Also, let's not forget that
the Iranians have been studying Sorry,
sorry, sorry. The Americans have been
studying um the
um American strategy in the Middle East
for the past 20 years. And I'm pretty
sure they developed counter strategies
against an American attack. And I think
the main main um counter strategy is the
idea of decentralization. You've got
these different militias, different
cells embedded in different parts of of
Iran. So even though America and Israel
they may be able to decapitate the
leadership, they may be able to knock
out the central leadership in Tran um
they won't be able to occupy the country
and unless they're able to occupy the
country and install a military regime
that's to their liking then um this war
is not won then then then Iran is still
a functioning um threat to um American
Middle East interests. Okay. Um having
gone through some broad analysis,
let's look at questions that um viewers
have been asking on my discord server.
Okay, so the first big question is will
nuclear weapons be used in this war at
any point? And my intuition tells me it
won't be okay for many many reasons.
Okay, the first major reason is this is
huge taboo against the use of nuclear
weapons. If America were to detonate a
nuke that America would lose all
credibility, all authority um um among
its allies and among among the world and
we we have to remember like a lot like
this war is being fought to reestablish
American credibility and authority in
the world. Um Putin's invasion of
Ukraine did a great deal of damage to
Americans reputation and fighting this
war in Ukraine is to reestablish the
idea that America is still the global
hedgeimon that is still a unipolar
world. And so by getting a nuke it shows
the desperation, anxiety um and quite
honestly incompetence of the American
military. Okay. So I so for that reason
I don't think America will use nukes.
Also, even though Putin has not publicly
stated um that he will he will retaliate
if America will use a nuke against Iran,
he hasn't done this publicly because
it's not to his advantage to state to
say it publicly. But I'm sure that
through back channels through uh inter
intermediaries uh Putin has made this
very clear to the Americans and Putin
will tolerate an American invasion of
Iran but he will not tolerate
um uh nuclear weapons being used in this
war. So I think we can discount
um the use of nukes in this war. um we
have to we would have to reach a very uh
high point in escalation ladder for even
nukes to be considered in this war.
Okay. So I think like for the purpose
purpose of analysis let's discount the
possibility of nukes.
Second question is um what are unknowns
in going into this war? Okay. Well I
think there are three big unknowns. The
first big unknown is what happens if the
Americans kill the supreme leader of
Iran. this would trigger a sess
cessation crisis. Um his son um is
supposed to
uh take over in the case of the death of
the Ayatollah, but he's extremely
unpopular and he's he's he's not that
competent. So I'm not sure if um the
death of the sup supreme leader, the
assassination of the supreme leader,
what that would do to the dynamic of
this war. But I would assume that this
would be a huge advantage for uh for the
Americans and the Israelis. So I think
that's a big question. Are they will
they be able to assassinate the supreme
leader? Okay, that's the first big
question. Second big question is what
will Putin's response be? Um, and I
think I think as we know Putin has
withdrawn a lot of of his Soviet a lot
of his Russian adviserss from Iran and
Putin has stayed pretty quiet um in the
matter and um so um what he intends
um what he will do we just don't know
right now and I think that's the
intention. I I think Putin um wants to
be the power broker behind the scenes.
Um and I think um in many ways he's
setting up a trap for America because
um there's really one scenario in which
America loses this war. Okay, really
badly. Um if America would send in
ground troops, it would lose this war.
And the reason why is the idea of sunk
cost fallacy. All right. So, so if
America were to send in the Marines and
a ground invasion, we can expect the
American military would just bulldoze
all position. It would establish um uh
beach heads. It would establish um fort
operating bases throughout the interior
of Iran. And at this point, everyone's
like cheering on like look how great the
American military is. There's a surge of
patriotism in America. the American
media, CNN, New York Times, they are
just placing the American military to
the sky. And um it would be it it would
seem a repeat of Operation Desert Storm
in 2003. The problem though is the
American military does not have the
death, the strategic death, the
resources, the supply lines in order to
sustain this attack. And what would
happen very quickly is this massive
blitz crack, shock and all, whatever you
call it, um, in Iran would get bogged
down really quickly. And at this point,
it' be very easy for the underground
militias, these, um, these cell groups
to strike at supply lines for the
Americans. and and it'll become very
quickly almost an almost an impossible
um war to win for the uh uh for the
Americans and um but at the same time
they've invested so much and they're so
close to tan right they're so close to
taking over the capital so they can't
give up it's sunk cost fallacy and saus
fallacy is such a powerful force in
geopolitics and so the um the Americans
are kind of stuck there and then they're
just forced to it's a black hole for
them. They're just forced to throw in
resources
um that they don't have and this might
trigger um well this this will
definitely trigger protest across
America which may lead to a civil war.
Um so remember it's impossible for any
nation in this world to defeat America
just impossible. All right? Right? Even
if the entire world were to get together
and attack America, the world the world
would still lose. The only way to defeat
America is by causing a civil war, a
revolution in America that would damage
the regime so much that America would be
forced to retreat from its obligations
in the world. Okay. So my question then
is does Putin understand this? And he
has set he set up conditions in a way to
create this outcome. And my thinking is
yes, Putin, this is Putin's plan moving
forward and Putin will be working behind
the scenes in order to create a
situation where America is forced to um
uh invade uh Iran with ground forces.
The these ground forces will seem to be
really quickly establish
supremacy in Iran, but they get bogged
down and then Trump the Americans may be
forced to have a draft. Um and this will
lead to Vietnam war protests and
conflicts across uh America which may in
the end trigger an American civil war.
So that's um Putin and Russia and but
again we don't know exactly what they
will do but if I'm right about Putin
then um I think he will very much be the
mass manipulator behind the scenes. The
third great unknown is China. Um, China
and Iran have very strong economic ties.
China gets a third to half its oil from
Iran. If Iran were to fall and America
were to control the oil supply, then the
Chinese economy would be in a lot of
trouble. Geopolitically, this would be
very very bad for China. Um, so that so
China is a great unknown. What what's
what will China's response be?
My prediction is we will not hear from
China in this conflict that much. In
fact, we can sort of discount China from
uh from this war. And there are reasons
why. Okay, the first major reason is
China doesn't really have a grand
geopolitical strategy. It doesn't really
understand its place in the world. It
doesn't have a theory to explain its
place in the world. So remember um
previously I discussed the heartland
thesis, the Mckender thesis where both
America and Britain need to um stop a
hedgemon emerging to unite the Eurasian
continent. Okay? Because if if a land
power would emerge, maybe Germany, maybe
Russia were able to unite Europe and
Asia together, then um that would
destroy America and Britain's capacity
to control global trade, right? You can
have railways connect Eurasia and you
really don't have to trade for the seas
anymore. So that's the um that's how
America and Britain sees the world. Uh
Russia understands that it is extremely
vulnerable to invasions. It been it's
been invaded by uh multiple nations in
its history which has caused tremendous
death and destruction within Russia. So
Russia needs to be on the offensive if
it is to maintain its if if it is to
maintain its territorial integrity.
Okay. But when we go to China, China
doesn't really care about the rest of
the world. Um for China what's important
is to maintain its territorial integrity
by not participating in the world. Uh
China built the great wall and the
purpose of the great wall was to prevent
outsiders from coming to China but also
to prevent insiders from leaving China.
Um so for China its main priority is to
maintain its inter territory integrity
and what it understands is um the only
way for the communist party to fall in
China is if it were to engage itself in
an external geopolitical conflict that
has no way of extruding itself from.
That's why China is not going to get
involved in this war in the Middle East.
And at the end of the day, if the United
States conquers Iran and forces China to
pay twice, three, four times as much for
oil, then China will just absorb the
cost. Uh because for China, what's
really important is to maintain the
stability of the regime. The
geopolitical geopolitics doesn't really
matter. Okay. So, I would say these are
the three big questions moving forward
that we can watch out for. um will the
Americans be able to kill the Supreme
Leader because that is definitely on the
agenda and they're investing a lot of
resources to ensure this possibility and
I'm not sure if it will happen. Um but
if the conse but if it does happen then
consequences for Iran will be quite
dire. Okay. Um another unknown is Russia
what Putin will do. um we
um I think it it it will be all almost
be impossible to truly gauge his
intentions and strategy moving forward.
Now known as China will China
participate in this uh conflict on the
side of Iran.
Um my guess my prediction is if there is
participation it'll be much more it'll
be very limited. So China will supply
supplies uh armaments but it will not um
intervene on behalf of Iran um to the
degree that Iran would would really
want. Okay. So um um one last thing I
want to talk about is some of you have
been curious as to how I've been able to
so accurately predict um the contours of
this war. And so the quick answer to
this is I use a new analytical model
called game theory. And um game theory
is something that I will discuss in
greater detail um over the next few
months as I analyze this war even more.
Um and um game theory is not a secret. I
mean it's it is not something that's
impossible to learn. Uh my hope as we
move along is to teach everyone the
ability to use game theory to analyze
geopolitics in order to anticipate
events and to prepare for events. Um so
um that's it for my first analysis of
this war. I'm hoping to make more more
more updates as this war progresses. Um,
and um, so there's lots of things I
could I can't really talk about on
YouTube because I'll be banned or I'll
be censored. So, as some of you know, I
had a German video. I I I I made a um
video on the history of Germany and
that's been banned in Germany by by
YouTube because it was flagged by
certain users who found some material
within the video extremely
controversial. Um, so, um, so I need to
be really careful about what I say in
order to avoid YouTube censorship. I'll
probably at some point, uh, move to
Rumble where I'll be more free to
discuss what I really think about the
world. Um, um, so um, please watch out
for that. I'll make an announcement if I
move on to Rumble. Okay. But, uh, the
big announcement is I've set I set up a
Discord server. As some of you know,
this Discord server will allow us to
engage as a community. And what I'm
hoping to do at some point is set up um
a time for where we can have question
answer where you can like ask me
anything and I'll tell you how I um how
how my thought process works and and and
guide you through the process of
developing a game theory mindset. So you
can for yourself analyze global events
using uh game theory. So um the link to
my discord server called predictive
history it's it's in it's in the
description. Uh so please click on that
and please join uh the server the
discord server and um very quickly we'll
set up like an hour uh live stream where
I'll answer some questions that you have
posted on the discord server. I
apologize if I'm if I'm not responding
to your messages. Um I have two young
boys who are running around the park
right now and I have to watch them and
um they're very active. Um and they're
suffering from jet lag. So I'm taking
out I'm taking them out on strolls to
the parks every single day. So I'm
usually not at home. I don't have
internet access um outside uh my my
parents house. So I apologize if I'm
responding to you um in in real time to
your queries and to your message. Um I
am extremely faith thankful and grateful
for the community that we we're
developing right now and I hope to uh
build on on this community because as
some of you have pointed out the world
is moving to a very dark place and the
only way to sur survive and to
anticipate and to prepare for the chaos
that this new world will bring about is
to come together as community and to
help each other out and to have
solidarity. Okay. So, please join the
the Discord server and uh I will see
everyone on Discord. So, um goodbye.